die These ist die Ampel hatten
Wackelkontakt die ist eigentlich schon
ziemlich runtergerockt also ich habe im
Dezember als die neue Regierung sich
gebildet hat nach den
koalitionswarnungen gedacht wow das
waren schon beeindruckende
koalitionsverhandlung das war wenig
öffentlicher Streit und sondern dachte
jetzt wird richtig schwer wahrscheinlich
für so eine Position wenn die so
regieren wie situationsverhandlung
geführt haben und es war ja schon im
Januar damit vorbei dann werden das
Thema verpflichtende Impfung egal jetzt
wie man zu Impfpflicht steht egal jetzt
inhaltlich aber das sind Kanzler sagt
ich bin für eine Impfpflicht und was
soll man gruppenanträge so als wenn
Helmut Kohl den Euro per Gruppenantrag
eingeführt hätte also der fing es ja
schon mit an dass die Koalition nicht in
der Lage war an der Stelle einheitlich
aufzutreten und es hat sich halt bis
heute fortgesetzt ich meine das wäre
jetzt diese Woche erlebt haben rund um
den Verbrennermotor wo noch eben bis in
die Abstimmung in Brüssel hinein das war
nicht nur peinlich in Deutschland das
war peinlich in der ganzen Europäischen
Union per Twitter die Bundesregierung
ihre unterschiedlichen Positionen
austauscht es wird jede Woche was ange
nicht um die Bürger zu entlasten was
hohe Energiepreise angeht aber jeder
macht einen eigenen und einen anderen
Vorschlag entschieden wird aber nichts
Waffenlieferung da sagen FDP-Politiker
das Problem sitzt im Kanzleramt dass die
Waffen also es ist ja nicht die
Opposition die das sagt innerhalb der
eigenen Regierung wir sind irgendwie
nach acht Monaten dieser neuen Regierung
die eigentlich gut gestartet war mit
Koalitionsverhandlungen schon soweit bis
hin zum twitterstreit wie wir ein
schlechtesten großen Koalitionären
Zeiten nicht gewesen sind also das im
Umgang miteinander und das und das in so
einer Krise in der Zeit wo wir zumindest
mal das Risiko haben dass wenn zum
Beispiel Gas nicht mehr ausreichend
kommt etwa für die Industrie wo wir in
Arbeitslosigkeit hineingehen
möglicherweise in Rezessionen Kurzarbeit
in der Zeit wo es mehr denn je darauf
ankommt das Handlungsfähigkeit da ist
das entschieden wird da sind wir wieder
auch manchmal bei es schnell entschieden
wird wenn es darauf ankommt hat diese
Koalition und diese Ampeln ziemlich in
Wackelkontakt und das ist nicht gut
sie müssen sich weniger Sorgen um die
Ampel machen dass diese Ampel keine
liebes
Hochzeit war zu Beginn dass wir
teilweise dir mitral andere Politik
Ansätze haben auch in den Wahlprogrammen
haben wir immer gesagt wir haben uns in
den
Koalitionsverhandlungen miteinander
eine vereinbart dass wir einen anderen
Stil pflegen dazu gehört aber auch dass
man die Unterschiede der einzelnen
Partner so in der Öffentlichkeit auch
durchaus wahrnimmt das ja vielleicht
auch ein Unterschied zur großen
Koalition zum letzten zwei Legislaturen
große Koalition wo am Ende des Tages gar
kein Unterschied mehr da war wer am Ende
Union oder SPD wofür verantwortlich war
und dann haben wir in der Tat eine
Situation
sie hatten paar Jahre als
Gesundheitsminister an Vorbereitung um
sich auch auf Pandemien vorzubereiten
wir haben keine 100 Tage gehabt wo wir
corona-welle die noch durch den Winter
durchging mit mangelhafter Vorbereitung
der Vorgängerregierung und ein Krieg
Ukraine aufgrund des Angriffs von
Russland hatten so und wir haben jetzt
eine Reihe von Themen die wir angehen
müssen und die gehen wir an also nur als
Beispiel zum Thema manchmal muss man
schnell entscheiden Sie und Ihre Union
wollten im März ein einseitiges
gas-schuldenverantwortung gut findet ist
immer ein bisschen so wie sich eben
versucht haben aus ihrem
corona-management rauszureden am Ende
des Tages muss man die Themen dann auch
so bearbeiten dass es funktioniert und
der Weg den sie im März vorgeschlagen
hätten wären Massenarbeitslosigkeit
gewesen wären Wirtschaftseinbruch in
sechs sieben Prozent gewesen wir haben
jetzt eine Situation und da bin ich ja
durchaus bei Ihnen das gebe ich Ihnen
eine
ich gebe ihnen ich gebe ihnen ich gebe
ihnen durchaus recht dass die FDP sich
wünschen würde oder gewünscht hätte dass
schaffen schneller in die Ukraine
geliefert werden das haben wir immer
gemacht ich glaube wir garantieren oder
haben auch durch unser intervenieren im
April was Anträge die sie auch
mitgetragen haben im Deutschen Bundestag
als Union klar gemacht dass wir hier den
Kurs der Ampel auch entsprechend
revidiert haben es ist sicherlich so
dass auch das Umstellen auf
Kohlekraftwerke die jetzt im Juli
anlaufen werden aus unserer Perspektive
hätten schneller gehen können das will
ich gar nicht in Abrede stellen aber so
zu tun als ob wir die Probleme die wir
wie gesagt 16 Jahre CDU geführte
Bundesregierung übernehmen übernehmen
mussten Stichwort
16 Jahre Kohle Kohle
unser neuer Stil so jetzt kommen wir mal
ein Thema wo sie nicht immer ist auf
andere schieben können diese
Bundesregierung brauchte für die
Abstimmung in diesem Jahr in diesem in
dieser Woche im Rad in Brüssel oder
Luxemburg wo immer digital eine
einheitliche Position und sie war bis
zum Beginn der Sitzung nicht in der Lage
eine einheitliche Position zu haben und
es ging um für Deutschland geht es darum
ziemlich viel das ist ja so eine Debatte
verbrennerautos Autos sind eine Quelle
unseres Wohlstandes ob wir uns überhaupt
irgendwas leisten können oder nicht
etwas damit zu tun ob wir Autos in die
Welt verkaufen so dann erleben wir bis
in die Sitzung hinein ja bei Twitter wie
die Umweltministerin und der
Finanzminister irgendwie ihre unter sie
können sagen wir pflegen
unterschiedliche Positionen das ist
unser neuer Stil aber der kann ja
irgendwie nicht bedeuten dass da in
Brüssel irgendwie zwei verschiedene
Positionen vertreten werden sondern man
muss ja schon an der Lage sein
idealerweise das ich teile ja die
Position der FDP in der Sache aber sie
haben sich ja nicht durchgesetzt ich
meine am Ende kriegen wir dann erklärt
der Verbrennermotor nächster morgen alle
ganz stolz bleibt dann liest du dir die
Texte durch was wirklich beschlossen
worden ist und am Ende ist euer kleiner
Aufstand da per Twitter als Papiertiger
gelandet und wenn das der neue Stil des
Regierens entspannt
muss ich dazu
möchte
aber nur ein Satz also wenn der größte
deutsche Automobilzulieferer Bosch mit
dem gefundenen Kompromiss was e-funes
angeht zufrieden ist das auch in
Interviews sagt denn aber es gibt ganz
viele mittelständische
automobilzuliefern die überhaupt nicht
zufrieden sind wichtig wir hätten uns
eine andere Position gewünscht die
kommissionspräsidentin Frau van der
Leyen
CDU-Parteibuch hat mit ihrem fit sind
immer andere schneiden
gehen
aus welcher Perspektive zunächst erstmal
eine Positionierung kam und das
Verbrenner aus kam nicht von der FDP als
Position es wurde von einer
unionsregierten Bundesregierung
eingeführt und sie haben jetzt das beste
daraus gemacht dass die FDP haben dass
genau
die FDP es geht darum dass wir eine
Regierung haben aus drei Parteien wo wir
jeden Tag und das war jetzt ein Beispiel
die einen die Bürger sagen wann kommt
endlich unsere Entlastung die einen
sagen soziales Klima Geld die anderen
machen Tankrabatt oder Steuern senken
die dritten kommen irgendwie auch noch
mit einer Idee der Kanzler hat jetzt
auch eine Idee gehabt diese
Einmalzahlung muss man ja vorstellen der
Kanzler der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Einmalzahlung aus der Einmalzahlung wird
eine Eintagsfliege zwei Tage später
redet schon niemand darüber was der
Kanzler Deutschlands gesagt hat in der
Koalition ist es leicht zu den
aktengelegt worden und da bin ich halt
bei dem Punkt dass diese Ampel wenn das
der neue Stil ist jeder macht ständig
seine Vorschläge und macht so Seins und
am Ende werden keine Entscheidung
getroffen dann ist das einfach ein ich
konnte
man hat es doch jetzt verstanden also
worauf es hinausläuft Streit finde ich
allerdings ist gar nicht schlechtes in
einer Demokratie also wenn es in eine
Koalition der Button und Streit und
Konflikte gibt dann ist das doch
eigentlich nur ein Ausschuss aus der
Tatsache dass es verschiedene Parteien
sind mit verschiedenen
Grundüberzeugungen die da
zusammenarbeiten ich hätte mir oft
gewünscht in der Zeit der großen
Koalition dass da ein bisschen mehr
debattiert wird ich habe immer auf den
vereinigungsparteitag zwischen Union und
SPD gewartet so in manchen Phasen ja und
nein also
sie fühlen sich gut regiert
das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage also
ich würde sagen da warte ich noch so ein
bisschen ab aber die schwierigere
Situation im Vergleich zu der Koalition
hat ja im Moment die
Opposition würde ich sagen denn was ist
das denn für eine aussichtslose Lage
nach 16 Jahren Regierung man kann sich
nicht so recht Absetzen von von Frau
Merkel das geht nicht ja man
und welche neue welche neue Richtung die
Union eigentlich einschlägt und was für
was sie steht weiß ich immer noch nicht
so recht ja ich wissen wir waren jetzt
ein Versuch weil wir unbedingt noch Herr
Meyers Tier zu hören wollte wir schauen
jetzt ob sie sich nach dieser These gut
regiert fühlen ob Herr Meier sie
überzeugen kann jetzt von der Ampel also
nur ein letzten Satz ja wüsste gerne ich
habe es mir vor der letzten Wahl
wirklich überlegt ich wüsste gerne
ob es irgendeinen Grund gegeben hat oder
geben wird die Union zu wählen ich bin
jemals der dafür an super wäre aber ich
habe es bei der letzten Wahl einfach
nicht rausgekriegt was der Grund sein
könnte
zu viele diesen Grund nicht gesehen weil
wir hatten ein bitter schlechtes
Ergebnis aber wir sind wir sind
abgewählt worden da gibt es jetzt nichts
dran drumherum zu reden das können wir
jetzt auch noch mal aufarbeiten aber ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob das Wahlergebnis vom
letzten Jahr das müssen wir aufarbeiten
da haben wir echt ein Thema ich glaube
nicht dass das Hauptthema der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ist der ein Thema
ist gerade Krieg in der Ukraine die
Frage wie Deutschland sich da verhält
oder nicht verhält und das ist zusagt
und nicht hält dieses Thema ist
Energiepreise wie sind die Spritpreise
was passiert beim Gas das Thema ist ob
wir für unsere Industrie und für die
Arbeitsplätze eigentlich noch das Gas in
den nächsten Monaten als Energieform
kriegen wie wir es wie wir es brauchen
das Thema ist wie die Europäische Union
eigentlich zusammenbleibt weil da auch
schon die ersten Themen ja wieder
auftauchen in dieser schwierigen Zeit
deswegen kann man sich gerne den ganzen
Tag an den 16 Jahren abarbeiten ist
alles okay ich stelle mich jeder Debatte
ich weiß halt nur nicht ob das so
richtig die Problemlage trifft in der
dieses Land gerade ist wir sind hier
alle
ich möchte Entscheidungen
zu Wort kommen lassen Frau Gabert wenn
Sie das zu hören wenn zwei Politiker
sich so streiten in mir ins Bürgerin
weckt das immer Gefühl von Beklemmung
weil ich denke lasst uns doch über die
Probleme reden und nicht immer wer
Schuld hat aber denkt das denn in ihnen
wir sind halt als Bürger verunsichert
wir wissen nicht wo es hingeht und
Streit ist ja schön und gut aber muss ja
wirklich in der Öffentlichkeit
ausgetragen werden und wieso gibt es
nicht einfach Lösungen es sieht halt
wirklich aus zu jeder Lösung bringt der
Politiker ein Problem und es müssen
einfach Lösungen her und klar wie schon
vorher gesagt habe es ist nicht so
leicht da gibt es die einen die das
Klima schützen wollen dann gibt es
natürlich auch die wirtschaftliche Lage
und es ist alles unter einen Hut zu
bringen ist halt verdammt schwer und es
muss jetzt aber gemacht werden und diese
unbequemen Fragen müssen jetzt
beantwortet werden und hoffentlich
zeitnah